when you're afraid of something you have
to master it that's how you start to
overcome it outside that box is all
these possibilities of life what we do
is we shackled our mind we are a
prisoner in her own mind that this is
all I can do I was a weak mom you know a
weak-minded person so I mastered my mind
and it matched in my mind I mastered the
human mind need motivation watch it top
ten with believe nation
he's David Goggins and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success volume seven
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be open-minded I never thought in my
wildest dreams I could be a Navy SEAL
it's until you opened your mind open
mindedness creates that we all shut down
our my like for instance and I broke the
pull-up record everybody around me you
heard the poor prick was 4020 pull-ups
that's the first thing they did oh my
god four thousand and twenty four hours
or yeah it's four thousand twenty plus
of 24-hour period uh yeah the first
thing I did verses closing our minds
like oh my god that's crazy I wait and
got a pin it if it happens every minute
exactly every hour every second it's
taking life it make it not to be this
grandiose thing stop breaking it down
start breaking it down and most of us we
live in a box and we don't want to go
outside that box at all ever outside
that box is all these possibilities of
life but we do is we shackle our mind we
are a prisoner in our own mind that this
is all I can do it's all I'm good at and
we we take away the possible is if you
could be this you could be that you
could be all these things and I never
thought it 300 pounds I could be [ __ ]
soon Wow so if my mind was shackled me
and you would never meet
there'd be no book right there be no
book right there'd be nothing so but
people are saying that they live for
themselves not knowing that you have the
power within yourself to change millions
of lives yeah by face of life
rule number two enjoy the moment the
reason why we go back to old habits is
because our goals are too lofty
we're not achieving our goals fast
enough so what happens is you know what
oh man we're very impatient nowadays for
me it was good I have a phone I was I
was I was out of this world by myself it
was a race against David Goggins
it wouldn't race against God I'm gonna
look good for this person to that person
it was me I got to change myself so for
me if I lost five pounds in a week I got
a feeling I allowed myself to feel proud
of that I didn't look I got lose a
hundred and six pounds I'm like man I
went from 297 now I'm 292 in one week
man I'm killing it we don't we're not
proud of ourselves for the small
accomplishments what we need is we need
this monstrosity of the thing to happen
say I did it now there's a process that
you have to go through and patience is
the process and if we don't have
patience after a week I haven't lost 30
pounds and I'm done I'm over it so
that's why I found out with people man
they're not patient enough to realize
and to enjoy the moment not living it
just enjoy it
there's no finish line in life but enjoy
that moment Roger that man lost 5 let me
go 10 next week so that's the whole
thing about it that's how people lose it
rule number three change your mentality
you get the opportunity to become a Navy
SEAL and then you end up going through
buds three times I was very fortunate to
go through three times and not in this a
distich way in a life changing growing
way I found out so much about myself
through going through that training
three times and I went through the
hardest part of the training three times
you know after the fruit so first phase
is a crucible man and that's where I was
at for three times I spent most of my
time and buds at first base and the hell
week in the hell weeks and being in that
grind and in that grind I got time to
examine myself I caught the live autopsy
and also examine other people because I
was really good about putting people way
above me because I was I wasn't I was
never nobody so for me to be on the same
stage as these greats want to be Navy
SEALs and Buzz trained like my god you
guys are amazing I actually got here
with the wall thank you so much for
allowing me into play but as I was there
for so long
I got really
a chance to sit back because now the
cold waters is water now it's not our
code anymore your mind starts to change
they said get in the water
most people think about it for you it
became my life so I started learning
that if you try to change your mindset
versus it being like oh my god this
sucks
I became a professional blood student so
I wasn't gonna leave and so I graduated
so I started realizing if this is my
home this is what I am I had to always
reset the bar I had to reset my new norm
there always had to be a new norm so one
thing we don't do is we don't have a new
norm my new norm is you get up every
morning at 4 o'clock and you suffer
this is your new norm that became my new
life most people want to get out of it I
said no this is your new life this is
who you are you your new norm as you
wake up and you suffer and I started
realizing if that's my mentality
this should ain't hard anymore for her
your new norms you wake up you're
getting the cold water you get a beer to
this done whenever they say you're out
you get out so my new norm so I I do
that now today my new norm now is if I'm
doing tours in my run your new norm now
man is you they're doing tour marks the
Roger that mentality that's it man rule
number four act on your feelings
I don't live on the surface of anything
yeah surface is what got me raw at it
got me from a herd of 75 pounds at 300
pounds tell everybody I'm good I don't I
don't give a damn I'm good
no they're hollow words mmm a lot of us
speaking hollow words I used to speak in
hollow words I don't do anymore
everything that comes out mouth has
substance it's real and we all have
these feelings in our bodies in our
minds and our souls I act on mine a lot
of us who are afraid of something we
allow our minds to choose the path of
least resistance or we go a different
route I'm afraid of something is telling
me you must do their thing you must do
that yeah you have to go that way and
most of us don't understand that
mentality we go left and we wonder why
we haven't fulfilled something
lives is because we continue to take the
journey that is mapped out and how I
look at is I I talk in life like a lot
of us in life want to take the four-lane
highway that has roadmaps and all this
other stuff on it man tells you where to
go gas stations the next 10 miles up you
can see in McDonald's a Cracker Barrel
yeah it's the easy route very few is
gonna go to the right side also if you
want to be confident like David Goggins
and others check out my 254 confident
series the link is in the description
below and it's free you will never learn
from people if we always tap-dance
around the truth everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today rule number five adapt to the
suck a lot of us dream big you should
dream big dream big is important you
know some toys won't be doctors lawyers
dentists towards money I want one of
these special operations so you have
this big dream you can see so clear like
it's right in the front you can go out
and touch it but the thing about it is
somewhere if you dream big enough
somewhere down that journey that dream
becomes a nightmare and what happens in
that nightmare so they have all these
questions like if you want to be a
special ops you may not be a great
swimmer you may just realize that I'm
not great some out on that great runner
you may start to fail tests and all
these questions start to flood your mind
why am I here I'm not good enough trust
me I know all about the questions they
will flood your mind if you do not have
the answers for them you will quit the
answers lie in the repetitions you must
not forget the repetitions you put into
trying to dominate the crap that you're
in today
always always embrace the suck adapt to
the suck rule number six use your cookie
jar when you're afraid of something you
have to master it that's how you start
to overcome it so what I realized when I
get to that point where I want to quit
everybody they get the point where they
want to quit this is what happens the
mind tells you let's go home let's take
a warm shower let's get some food this
is not right this is that if you cannot
answer the questions at that moment
because your minds gonna start giving
you all these questions all these
questions
and if you can't answer them you're
going to quit what I realized when I was
going through buds Ranger School Officer
hundred mile race towards at my races
pull-up records my mind would come
creeping in like I was doing 4030 poops
that mm pull of us and my hands are
ripped open my mind said look brother
we've done all these other things you've
proven yourself you're good if I didn't
have the answer to respond to my mind
and say why I'm here why I'm doing this
you will always lose that fight you have
to have the response to what your mind
is gonna tell you another thing about
that is self-talk a lot of people have
like these big for on mental toughness
all this crap about self-talk
visualization it's true but the thing
about self talking all these things they
ask me what do you think about when
you're on mile 100 of a tours and a
5-mile run what are you thinking about
when you realize you've run for 24 hours
and you have 24 more hours to run and
yet another 105 miles what goes through
your mind what do you say to yourself I
want to know a lot of people think
self-talk works it does but doesn't work
without the suffering before your mind
starts saying we need self-talk so what
I tell myself is I go back to the months
in years of preparation to get to that
day and I'm telling myself the 3:30 in
the morning and I'm looking at my shoes
and I want to go out there and run 30
miles I have to in that second in that
moment of this self-talk my mind saying
you gotta find more you gotta find more
I once again calm down go back into my
mind and my cookie jar I call it and I
had to reflect back on this and I did to
get here and that because my self-talk
self-talk does not work unless it is
real most of us lie to ourselves in this
sub doesn't work it has to be real has
to be something that you've done to make
it really work rule number seven live
your life to the max we lost you the
most well haunts me most is that if I
would have died at 300 pounds let's say
I was 75 years old
I got to heaven and God has a chart like
that on everybody's life God knows all
let's say that I don't care what you
believe in doesn't matter I'm not
judging anybody let's say my thing is
God you get to heaven I'm finishing
pounds I sit down I was a cockroach
terminated my whole life and we're
sitting down just like this you're God
and I'm David and he gives me that chart
and he says look at this now look at
this chart and on the chart it has all
these different things but my name's on
it but these things aren't me I was
going to change the world I was going to
move I'm gonna set records gonna be a
Navy SEAL it's gonna be all these things
the military that I accomplish here to
get the VFW award you get be honored
here honor dare I'm like God I was this
isn't me like it says David Goggins I
was an Ecolab guy sprayed for
cockroaches and I'm 300 pounds stay here
I'm 185 it says here I got a bachelor's
in the masters it says all these things
and God goes no that's who you were
supposed to be Wow my biggest fear in
life is that there is a final resting
place in this world and there's a final
judgment and you talk to something much
bigger than you I don't want to sit down
and have a conversation with someone
with something that says you're in
heaven this is what you should have been
on earth and are you really in heaven
now are you in hell mm thinking about
how much I left on a table for fear for
not willing to go over the wall and over
the next wall and over the next wall so
my mind I believe that and God knows all
at least I believe that I want God to be
up there right now as we're speaking
writing stuff down saying my god he
exceeded even my expectations that's how
I lived my life I now know that there is
no cap on the human mind there's no cap
recapping ourselves
rule number eight take souls when you
grow up weak and you start to master
your mind because my whole thing is
whenever
whenever I'm weakest something wherever
I'm scared of something I master it I
was a weak my you know a weak-minded
person so I mastered my mind and it
matched in my mind I mastered the human
mind and I realized why I no longer
judge people why I don't like to put
people in a pedestal
cuz we're all up in our way we all have
demons some people hide them better than
other people so I know we all have them
by me knowing that I know the most alpha
males are very fragile very fragile they
never want to see another person harder
than them especially in that kind of ego
etosha ego father is strong ego of every
time ego was serious so if I can hurt
your ego I got you so by me having such
a fragile ego growing up all this was my
event I was doing a lot autopsy on how
tough I was okay this me up I've been
telling people to so I started using all
these different tools and tactics to get
in the structures heads and the taking
souls that's what happened man
we were Wednesday freezing cold
everybody's jackhammer and everybody's
everybody wants to you know everybody's
just want to get through it now
jackhammer ins when you just can't stop
can't stop shivering you know you're
sitting this uncontrolled be
jackhammering and the instructors take
great pride in watching you suffer they
do we're you know in in a sick way it's
kind of funny you know you know you were
there once as a student now your
instructor but I knew how would I be
thinking if I was in this truck I would
love seeing this sadistic go on but what
were out what wouldn't I like to see I
would hate to see some guys just looking
like this is just another day on the
beach and go for yourself I would hate
to see that so I don't want to think
like that when they did if they were
harder they were harder yeah everybody's
horse I see know what man it's time you
all I can't fight you
you guys can me up all day long that's
your job and I love your job I love what
you guys are doing you guys making this
better but now I want to take the
tactical van and I wanna start with you
so I got my boat crew Bill Brown I had
Chris Kyle on my boat crew American I've
had a couple of hardcore and everybody
right now is kind of like in their own
world
let's just get through this man I can't
wait til Friday so we
actually how we can get going I said
let's go ahead and have some fun I said
we're gonna stuff with these guys so the
evolution here was we got to with Matt
check you know we're stripped down to
nothing and they're checking us out
making sure we're good to you know
second front of Mon your second from
Japanese my knees all jacked up but
they're giving me shots in and I would
like to boat crew leader of boat crew
too so I'm in the front of boat and I
tell our guys this we're going to do the
boats like on our heads salt was we're
supposed to lift the boats up above our
head so I got do but when you're this
week in this fragile this tired their
boats heavy so there's a thing you can
do when you do boat presses so you can
get the boat and like just toss it up
toss it up and catch it and that shows
like you're jacked up so everybody's
holding the boat and they're shaking and
they both start to come down their head
and all the boat crews are all lined up
and they're up now I'm looking at that
and I turn around my broker I said guys
it's time to take some Souls everybody
what the you talking about I said we're
good structure is out here on their
jackets and drinking coffee and laughing
and smiling I want their faces to go
straight up numb so we're gonna do this
we can start boat pressing this money
just take my lead trust me you'll get
energy from it we start throwing this
boat up in the air cache the toilet for
kissing you chuckling can't hurt no crew
to wear your own ass off if we do it and
they make a stop like what the like to
stop I look at these instructors and
their faces literally look like someone
like just like took their soul like I
know where their minds were like they
were thinking about themselves like what
just happened man I know me always that
could've done that how they doing it so
the rest of time going through hell week
it was like we just you know that we
owned it right boat crew - we won every
single race we were just dominating and
it was uh it was a strong boat crew and
that's we're taking souls is uh there's
a few taking soil stories but that's one
of them rule number nine you suffering
to improve a lot of us don't know of a
whole nother world that exists it's on
the other side of suffering
once you break these barriers that you
have made for yourself like the mind is
the most powerful thing in the world in
the world it is so amazing the ice to be
a 300-pound guy and I thought that was
it could barely read could do anything
and now that what was inside that person
was this guy that's in front of the day
that's how scary the mind is and that's
what I started realizing through this
journey is that once I got a taste of
wow man I haven't even cracked I haven't
even begun to crack what the mind is
capable of and when I started realizing
is on the other end of suffering that's
the real growth of life because you
realize how the mind processes and I
talk about another thing called theory
and practice a lot of people are
theorists they these smart guys that
read these books and man and they sit
down they tell you what the mind is
supposed to do and a lot of us listen to
that it becomes like this is it man this
this old man who has been studying the
mind forever this is the cap that we
have by being a practitioner I went out
and realized a lot of these guys are so
wrong man the mind has capabilities that
are so unknown I found that through
suffering and there's a whole nother
world on the other end of that and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is do whatever it
takes only answer go for broke in my
life 27 years ago on that spot and
there's gas me the question yesterday
who's across the river he asked if
you're paying the price physically now
for what you put your body through am I
paying the price so mass was yes I hear
but what he didn't know was literally I
stepped back into my stomach
Luke the accountability here and I saw a
flex night like it wasn't so much the
outside there's a lot of the inside so
that bothered me and I was willing to do
whatever it took to change that
reflection you gotta find out what you
want to do to change the reflection that
kind of duty bearing now I've got a
special bonus clip on how to discover
who you are but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching or the video
to taking action here we go question
number one
what suffering will you use to improve
number two whose soul are you going to
take this week and number three where do
you need to change your mentality you
have to learn what do you want in your
life we have so much influence coming at
us that we are so lost we all know what
we want to do because we don't spend
enough time with ourselves you have to
learn to shut off a phone shut off a
computer shut off a TV and it's okay to
sit in the room by yourself in a chair
and just think about you where I want to
be where do I see myself tomorrow the
next year the next year from that and it
takes a lot of self-discipline to be
able to do that nowadays because you
want to be so it so attached to
everything you want to be so caught up
with the world the world is moving too
fast the world's moving so fast that
you're trying to keep up to the point
where you lose yourself in the world so
you have to take that time and go to
that dark place in your mind and
discover who you are
if you want more David Goggins check out
the top 15 rules your video man in him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there whole
thing about comfort zones is if you live
in one for too long that becomes your
norm you can outwork anybody